tenemos este rectángulo amarillo de acá
y comencé a llenarlo con estos cuadrados
de color verde mi pregunta para ustedes
y para mí es cuál es el número total de
cuadrados verdes que pueden caber aquí
en este rectángulo amarillo sin que se
sobrepongan unos con otros
veamos ya tenemos uno dos tres cuatro
cuadrados verdes agreguemos algunos más
puedo poner un honor justo aquí
y puedo poner otro aquí al lado
así que voy a tener 1 2 3 4 5 y 6
cuadrados verdes que caben perfectamente
en este rectángulo amarillo ahora veamos
este cuadrado amarillo grandote tenemos
lo mismo aquí ya comencé a llenarlos con
algunos cuadrados verdes y mi pregunta
es cuál es el número total de cuadrados
verdes que puedo poner aquí bueno en
este espacio de acá puedo poner otro
cuadrado que tiene el mismo tamaño que
los cuadrados verdes aquí voy a dibujar
otro cuadraron primero los dibujos y
después los contamos aquí hay otro
y aquí justamente cabe otro cuadrado y
ahora sí vamos a contarlos nos caben
123456789 de estos cuadrados verdes
pequeños dentro de este cuadrado
amarillo grande